bonsoir paul haslinger merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france bienvenus
c'est donc la première fois qu'on y
serait d'un chef du gouvernement en
exercice est inculpé cela peut-il avoir
un impact sur les élections législatives
prévue dans un mois et demi
et si ce qui est cru tant qu'ils ne
cesseraient aussi à la nordique à ces
élections auront lieu le 23 mars l'a dit
à plusieurs reprises ce matin pour lui
de 0 c est politisé en vue de ces
élections
netanyahu et ses partisans avec des gens
plutôt adroit disent qu'ils veulent voir
plus que soutient qu'ils auront plus de
soutien lors de ces élections parce que
la population se rendra bien compte que
c'est ce qu'il ya une chasse aux
sorcières contre les médias judiciaire
essaye de discréditer lantagne a une
langue qu'ils sont certains que c'est
l'artt clients iront voter un grand
nombre et à gauche en disant que le
premier ministre est devant les
tribunaux il est corrompu et c'est
effectivement la première fois qu'un
chef du gouvernement en exercice est
inculpé et 3 c'est un argument
disons que les gens doivent ôter le
contre netanyahu le 23 mars la foule
devant le tribunal aujourd'hui et c'est
vraiment un cas qui divise le pays
alors paul à netanyahou lui aurait fait
une nouvelle fois les raisins cuse à
sion dont il fait l'objet
clairement même si on n'est pas dans un
tribunal ici bien sûr mais est une des
preuves suffisantes
apparemment pour qu'ils soient inculpés
dépenses
à qui on demande son de défense dit pas
du tout le procureur dit que si bien
assez il fait face à deux cas différents
des accusations de corruption de fraude
et d'abus de confiance
d'une part on dit que benjamin netanyahu
accepté des cadeaux et d'autre part
qu'il accepte et des dessous de table
qui le donnait des dessous de table afin
d'essayer d'obtenir des couleurs
positive
celui-ci pose il est condamné alors ils
pourraient se retrouver en prison
pendant beaucoup d'années également de
possibles
le procureur avait caïman d'albi ce soit
en difficulté cave il n'a pas assigné
les n'a pas respecté le protocole
judiciaire habituel et l'équipe de
benyamin netanyahou dit que tout le
processus est donc faussé alors combien
de temps pourrait durer ce procès suit
ça va prendre des années
c'est en tout cas le procès n'est pas
supprimée pour cause de manque de
preuves
cela pourrait prendre des années mais
netanyahu parle de chasse aux sorcières
il contre lui ils accusent l'opposition
et les médias ont indiqué que l'actrice
et le judiciaire ont formé une alliance
jeudi et samedi soir les grandes rues
étaient bloquées par des manifestants
qui agitaient drapeaux et qui ai demandé
à benyamin nétanyahou de démissionner à
cause de ces accusations politiques
extrêmement liés à ces élections à venir
le 23 mars
il ya d'une part le système judiciaire
et d'autre part le système politique où
on le rappelle le bénin
ici pas d'immunité en tant que premier
ministre quelle condamnation risque et
il pourrait signer concrètement les en
prison un jour et se retrouver en prison
effectivement et il a mené les experts
sur place il pourrait effectivement se
retrouver un brise en mille
mais le panier mais mezzagno essaye à
peu repoussé le tweet c'est et repousser
les élections qui sont prévues pour le
23 mars
si elles sont à le repousser peignez
lindt agneaux espère s'il est élu au
premier ministre et les sondages
indiquent qu'ils pourraient
effectivement remporté les élections il
pourrait rester premier ministre
on estime que benyamin nétanyahou
utiliserait sa position afin d'obtenir
l'immunité parlementaire et afin
d'adopter des lois de faire adopter des
lois des chances qu'un premier ministre
se retrouve devant les tribunaux si les
élections ont eu lieu alors que le
procès n'ait pas ne battra son plein le
procès pour effectivement durer
éternellement tu dis est elle si les
évidences sont suffisantes comme je lé
déjà évoquée alors le premier pourrait
se retrouver en prison
alors effectivement vous venez de le
dire ses partisans de netanyahu souhaite
ce report après les élections
législatives
le fait qu' il y est quand même une
bonne gestion en tout cas israël est un
modèle faut bien le dire dans le monde
sur la gestion du duc au vide avec 35 %
des israéliens qui sont déjà vaccinés
le gouvernement mène bien sa barque un
concrètement dans cette gestion de la
crise sanitaire parce que d'une certaine
manière ça pourrait peser en faveur de
benyamin nétanyahou dans cette affaire
ce qui est beaucoup d'israéliens 10 la
raison pour laquelle israël l'action est
pionnière dans la lutte contre la copie
et que non seulement il s'agit d'un
problème sanitaire mais également pour
benyamin nétanyahou d'un levier
politique
il a promis que d'ici à fin mars tout le
pays ont été vaccinées et effectivement
le taux de vaccination en israël est
bien plus élevé que dans le reste du
monde se moque en fille c'est peut-être
parce qu'il sera l'état en petit pays
parce que le système de santé est
excellent mais également que le
gouvernement à payer davantage pour les
doses des vaccins de pfizer et de
gouverneur du montana aux utilisent cet
argument le temps d'une paix afin de se
renforcer ses positions politiques et
certaines personnes en respect la dir
ont forcément le premier ministre a fait
un excellent travail contre lacko vite
votons pour lui cependant le prix
extrêmement divisée entre les soutiens
de l'agneau et ses opposants le cesm
donc je pense donc que sur place ont dit
que quel que soit le succès de
netanyahou plutôt le point de vue
sanitaire
une ceux qui ne l'aiment pas de vote pas
pour lui est ce qu'il est la bonne info
laisse donc que cette élection sera
encore une fois pour benyamin nétanyahou
et nous attendons une annonce de du
tribunal dans les jours à venir afin de
savoir s'il enquête contre lui une peine
yahoo va continuer maintenant même si
elle va être repoussée après les
élections du 23 mars
merci beaucoup voilà slayer jaune anis
portée internationale d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir